the Summer Olympics were to take place
in Tokyo starting July 24th blasting
through August this year and then the
corona virus broke down shutting
everything down worldwide the
International Olympic Committee bowing
to global pressure pressure brought on
by the novel coronavirus catastrophe it
wasn't so much of a shock but a
monumental task in figuring out the
logistics of what's next at a micro
level the athletes suffer the most
many we're looking at this as their only
shot and many now have to train an extra
year putting extra stress on their body
which subjects them to injury and just
wear and tear from age on a macro level
those most affected are the biggest
stakeholders including NBC which
broadcasting rights make up 73% of the
expected 5.9 billion dollars these gains
were to generate now they have to figure
out when they will host them next summer
or any time in 2021
and how NBC will fit that in with the
rest of their regularly scheduled
broadcasting so companies spend money on
when they spend money for the Olympics
they'll spend money on sponsorships on
activation around those sponsorships so
social media ad spots new product
launches and holistically we know that
the impact to consumers is much greater
if they spend across multiple channels
and that's typically what advertisers
will do to maximize the impact of that
Olympic sponsorship or that Olympic
advertising effect so advertisers were
expected to spend 1.2 billion dollars on
these summer games now without the gains
as an option there spend for this year
has to be distributed to other media
properties and events but those are few
and far between so they're left without
the platform of the Olympics which is
the second biggest sporting event in the
world
it's a huge loss of bringing folks
together where you have multiple global
reach that you would never have for
years big companies and small companies
will be impacted but the smaller players
may not have the budgets to it's a
really bolster they our brand during
this downturn that were experiencing
right now what I hope to happen is that
advertisers don't hold back on that
spend on that connection with consumers
because they're worried consumer
confidence is down because what will
then in a car is a vicious cycle of less
spending less innovation less
opportunity to connect with the customer
and less sales overall for everyone the
conservative estimate that these gains
would cost is fifteen billion dollars
some experts have that running up to
twenty five billion dollars but now with
the delay there could be an additional
two billion dollars tacked on in
construction in lost revenue and so
these could be the second costliest aims
in history
you